moi la maman la maman et bravo arthur
très très bien donne moi le papa papa
très bien demain le bb bb c'est super
d'autres journal arthur réussi
brillamment son test d'aptitude
huit mois plus tard c'est un grand jour
pour ses parents leur fils signent
aujourd'hui un cdi on est aujourd'hui
est vraiment très content de ce
dispositif est encore plus ravi qu
arthur d'où nous rejoignent et puis
voilà c'est que le début pour lui d'une
une longue aventure
et pour vous aussi voilà donc on va te
donner trop ton contrat à signer si tu
veux bien qu'il te plaît
la scène peut sembler banal mais arthur
n'est pas un jeune homme comme les
autres il est atteint du trouble du
spectre de l'autisme sa scolarité a été
compliqué pour sa maman
le chemin a été long je me suis détaché
vraiment de cette peur de l'avenir
d'avoir l'enfant parfait parce qu'il ya
quand même un deuil à faire dans
l'autisme de l'enfant parfait c'est tout
de suite quoi des conseils il faut agir
il faut pas laisser comme arthur il a
été pris en charge beaucoup trop
tardivement et je pense qu'effectivement
il aurait pu peut-être est verbale
aujourd'hui peut-être
faire des études on sait pas on sait pas
quand on est un parent d'enfant autiste
c'est certainement très compliqué et
très frustrant de ne pas pouvoir
communiquer et interagir avec son enfant
pour des raisons vraiment très affective
un enfant qui fait pas de câlins à un
enfant qui n'a pas de contact oculaire
un enfant qui ne présente pas de
réciprocité social ça doit être très
compliqué depuis la toute petite enfance
ça se manifeste par un enfant qui ne va
pas tendre les bras quand sa maman va
arriver pour le chercher dans son lit ou
qui ne va pas le regarder lorsqu'ils
mangent ou tête
l'autisme affecte le système nerveux dès
le ventre de la même communiqué est
difficile pour eux leur pensée est très
visuel la commande c'est novak à remplir
donc en fait il met 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 et
ils enlèvent à chaque fois qu'il a fait
un bac dans cette usine filiale d'andros
de 450 salariés
huit personnes autistes sont en cdi une
première en france
chaque matin de la semaine pendant trois
heures et demie les jeunes sont au
travail avec terence arthur ouvre les
cartons et trie les peaux l'espace est
entièrement organisé pour eux
chaque référence est signalé par un une
affiche de couleur de manière à ce que
les garçons se repère soit v avec le
chiffre soit avec la couleur en fonction
de leurs compétences pour traverser une
signalétique a été mise en place
c'est à nous de nous adapter au niveau
de compréhension de la personne donc si
vous suit fonctionne pas on le teste sur
un temps donné et définit aussi en
réunion et donc si l'outil fonctionne
pas dans le réadapter puisque l'objectif
c'est de s'adapter à la problématique de
la personne à son niveau de
compréhension et pâle inverse après la
matinée de travail les jeunes retournent
chez eux à la maison du parc situé aussi
à auneau en eure-et-loir un bâtiment
niché au coeur d'un jardin de 20
hectares il a été entièrement rénové par
andros est prêté à l'association vivre
et travailler autrement
la maison est financé par le conseil
départemental et par les loyers des
chambres payés par les autistes
[Musique]
où sont les hommes demande a poliment le
petit prince lafleur un jour avait vu
passer une caravane
tous les jours des activités sont
proposées à la maison du parc
on va essayer de partir de cette
histoire là pour dessiner
on va dessiner le petit prince le petit
prince
oui hélas l'udc c'est la fleur
enfin
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il y a un prénom comme
image mon à renard fait l'émotion du
moment et on ne cherche pas spécialement
à révéler quelque chose d'eux c'est un
moment où ils sont libres d'expression
le trouble du spectre de l'autisme
varient d'une personne à l'autre
certains parlent ou écrit il d'autres
nous donc vous pouvez avoir une personne
autiste qui présente des compétences
intellectuelles dans les normes voire
supérieurs à la norme
comme vous pouvez avoir une personne
autiste qui a une déficience
intellectuelle associés légère moyenne à
sévère
donc on a affaire à des pros profils
complètement différent on peut être
autiste et faire des études
luc travail chez andros et c'est grâce à
lui que le dispositif existe son père
jean françois dufresne directeur général
est à l'origine du projet il se bat pour
que les autistes travail car en france
seulement 5% montrent un emploi la
caractéristique française mais qui est
assez répandu de toute façon c'est de
considérer que quand on voit un handicap
et de se dire mais qu'est ce qui peut
pas faire qu'est-ce qui peut pas faire
et moi ce qui m'intéresse ce qu'est ce
qui peut faire et comment je l'aide à
pouvoir faire et pouvoir exprimer ses
compétences
l'objectif c'est qu'ils nous quittent
sais que certains d'entre eux ils n'y
arriveront peut-être pas tous mais que
certains d'entre eux puissent acquérir
un tel niveau d'autonomie qu'il puisse
aller travailler
peut-être par camille temps peut-être
pour certains à plein temps et que
parallèlement ils puissent avoir un
appartement en ville
[Musique]
pour
le lendemain retour chez andros place et
les yachts au chocolat et ensuite il ya
différents postes où chaque gène va
s'installer sur le poste sur lequel il
est installé et mis au niveau de la
photo
[Musique]
rainer caire jordan luc et louis mec les
couvercles sur les pots de yaourt
le fait de faire des tâches répétitives
ça rassure le jeune puisque du coup
c'est du quotidien c'est
la répétition
c'est rassurant pour eux
une tâche qui connaissent le campus sont
très productifs
pas d'envoi spa traumatique
toujours pareil répéter tous les jours
les mêmes actes aide les personnes
autistes certaines deviennent même ultra
compétitive
aujourd'hui pour être honnête les
semaines les moins bonne c'est les
semaines où les personnels autistes sont
pas là ils sont en congé parce que bon
avec les avec le temps ils ont
l'expérience du coup leur travail
aujourd'hui ils le font très vite ce qui
se perdent pas de temps à chercher à
comprendre
ils savent ce qu'ils ont à faire du
corps ne sont pas là on remplace par des
personnes intérimaires qui n'ont pas les
connaissances qui leur font un temps
d'apprentissage
certains après-midi arthur et une
équerre vont faire les courses ces
lignes les accompagnent on prend le bcra
et on va prendre des ravi ravi
[Musique]
oui
arthur d'avoir la dame à te demande pour
combien de personnes est allée d'où tu
veux quoi arthur tu veux quoi comme
poisson du lundi du 20e cabillaud
caillou
que faire bonjour
une souvent le lundi et enfin je n'ai
pas souvent à ma caisse ça bien parce
que ça peut leur permettre de de leur
prouver qu'ils peuvent être une bombe
[Musique]
tous les soirs les jeunes racontent leur
journée un rituel qui les force à
prendre la parole
cercle qui commande c'est parti à qui
est de raconter sa journée super terence
hill ont beaucoup de mal et initier les
choses ils ont besoin de nous pour ça et
là justement c'est ce qu'on travaille
avec eux c'est pour ça qu'au début on
dit qu'ils me le faire on leur propose
mais on désigne autant c'est pour qu'il
puisse avoir l'initiative et qu'ils
arrivent à demander de même c'est très
important au niveau
en
[Musique]
retour à l'entreprise à la pesée ce
travail fonctionne pour les autistes
mettriez les palettes par exemple a été
un échec
ils n'arrivent pas à juger de se dire
pour moi celle ci
allez un peu fragile mais ça passe quand
même où celle ci allait imposer ce
quinté mais ça va quand même pas c'est
c'est eh oui ou non on n'a pas pu trier
ici nous on a une certaine palette on
obligé de faire un compromis
et le compromis au niveau de l'autisme
se passe pas les jeunes maîtrisent ce
travail car ils apprennent à peser à la
maison parc mais à cuisine mais c'est
bien lui qu ici en fait je leur apprends
à un peu et correctement mais avec une
balance électrique parce qu'avec
l'aiguillé en fête ils ont beaucoup
beaucoup de mal ils n'arrivent pas à
associer en fait les grammages donc du
coup par contre si je le remets le petit
pic taux d'à côté 500 grammes avec ce
qu'ils doivent mettre sur la balance
c'est beaucoup plus facile pour eux
génial merci rémi 4 allez on y va
terence tu peux aller d'un manège
terence vas-y parmi les activités des
jeunes
l'équitation le cheval est une présence
apaisante
2 3 et ut ainsi doucement parfait c'est
aussi l'occasion de travailler
l'équilibré
voilà ok tu les fais une caresse c'est
bien
quand on part en balade j'essaye aussi
qu'ils soient pas trop passif sur le
cheval donc je les fais par exemple
s'arrêter repartir caresser caresser les
oreilles se pencher en balade
on a dans la forêt là ça monte ça
descend donc en montée ils doivent
adapter leurs positions en descend de
prendre une autre position
la journée se termine c'est le départ en
week end arthur va retrouver sa famille
il nettoie sa chance avant l'arrivée de
sa grande soeur il adore passer du temps
avec moi enfin s'est vu qu on de la même
tranche d'âge c'est ce qui devrait faire
normalement quoi sortir avec des amis
l'ont souvent quand j'ai des copines
bon bah on va on l'emmène avec nous il
est content quoi ici c'est vrai qu'il
est très bien ça lui correspond et c'est
tout ce qui compte pour nous en tout cas
[Musique]
l'enfance d'arthur a été compliqué
chaque sortie et est source d'angoissé
le regard des autres les insultes dans
la rue mais retraite multifils est
ouvert est ce qu'on peut dire c'est ici
ouvert il accepte beaucoup plus imprévus
il accepte beaucoup plus les autres ça
fait peur au début quand on vous
l'annonçait et puis finalement notre vie
s'est fait aussi autour et ma vie
professionnelle complètement été
bouleversée aussi grâce à arthur est une
grâce à arthur je suis la personne que
je suis aujourd'hui avoir un emploi et
être accompagnés pour les autistes c'est
une première en france
un exemple que deux autres entreprises
veulent mettre en place
jordan luc rennais guerre terence arthur
leurs membres peut nous paraître
étrangers mais tous ces jeunes évolue au
quotidien grâce à ces expériences ils
pourront peut-être un jour être autonome
[Musique]